[Music]
[Applause]
Amami Oshima is an island off the coast
of mainland Japan and while it's well
known for its thriving coral reefs and
sandy beaches its sumo that puts this
island on the map Amami Oshima takes
great pride in raising young boys to
become some of the country's best
wrestlers ataxia Morita zero to emo
Samia smoked Roberto Clemente te samosir
Dozier makan to post a masseuse
macoco de agua de panne dictionary data
in autumn with over 150 dokey O's or
sumo rings Amami Oshima has the highest
concentration of sumo facilities in
Japan making the sport accessible to
most young people on the island booked
on my Rob Lee Scott how do these small
walks they must to take what we're up to
into
[Music]
he's gone
underneath Caicos dead dogs dead serious
Philip but sumo is not only practiced as
a means for future success it's an on to
the islands history and has been
embedded in its culture for hundreds of
years
[Music]
annual festivals include sumo
tournaments where wrestlers come out to
participate own inside you know very
much their Amiga mean is a guru at the
devotin ahadith motor eaten raw in
cascara know it's there to study must
know their chief academic are our tuna
mother move mean elephant affiliate
gives this
but despite the islands efforts to
maintain sumo as a cultural staple the
sport has begun to decrease in
popularity among young people they will
kilometres ahead take students in cairo
Chiefs I should have been not even our
follow through material - finish their
mother need dental the get cigarettes
Buddhist terminology send a demo on our
radar ni naamam me gusta cuando la gente
está con s Adrenalina greetin o quand
overeaten cuando tha an cuando table
then detonate a mutiny here positiva es
que es una noche para la hoya creo que
una CIPA la lucha libre
mi nombre es Mariano's science missile
Doraemon a luchador AHA Nutella kirino's
m-pesa muy joven en la lucha leader no
había muchas oportunidades para las
mujeres en s entonces pero cuando ella
es Odell actually Toluca Dora
Oh moon boom pero también con una
Kritika now had a Panera smooch except
allah no insane a las piernas con
facilitate entonces en este report a
nosotros las normas de los altos de los
vuelos Casillas son
Zellman take Thomas Tom las piernas
literacy both critical they must
associate at the nose to miss McKay
marrow as a nosotros para la semaine
over my resume okay this is suez canal
Polaris is el mucho para tu si me gusta
la Chicanos hombres por que son el el
sexo más fuertes a business man father
Columba llamo Starla's que una mujer
tambien desperate a guard or sabemos que
las más fuerte para una center vision
sees mess
la laguna de estos companyís fini
familias oh yeah a luchador a madre
America's a speakeasy cloak a valium was
Moshe Kamali Chavez Sumer a saline is a
game of seconds however there's months
of training ago within those seconds
imagine it's like an earthquake that's
building and building and building and
all of a sudden there's this huge
explosion all at one time
that's what Singh was
[Music]
I'm really just a normal guy I'm a
husband I'm a father of three I'm the
director of technology for the County
Office of Education I'm also an American
soon we're outside
Summa has a long history in Japan some
people trace it back up to 1500 or 2000
years but it's essentially you know
wrestling where you either want to push
your opponent out of the ring or knock
your opponent to the ground
people have an image but sumo wrestlers
are basically just bumping bellies and
wobbling around and as you can see from
the practice here nothing's further from
the truth
Roy is amazing he basically came out of
nowhere he showed up to the 2014 US sumo
open and blew everyone's mind he beat
every single American opponent with
almost no training he's already the
number one American to be a competitive
sumo wrestler you need to train hard
whether I'm stretching with them
powerlifting whether I'm working out
with with rocks I'm always looking for
the edge the thing that really brought
me to sumo was the fact that there was
culture and sport all kind of mixed in
one it seemed like a perfect fit for
example when you stomp the ground you're
ridding the area of bad spirits and when
you make your first clap you're waking
up the gods you know he is a gentle
giant and he doesn't want to hurt
anybody and sumos great that way because
you know they're just trying to get each
other out of the ring they're not trying
to knock each other out or really hurt
hurt one another
I think sumo has a camaraderie
fraternity aspect to it you know we're
banging heads we're going at it at the
end of it there's still this higher
level of respect I guess as a pacifist
that definitely appeals to me in the
dressing room something happens while
I'm getting ready once I start putting
my makeup on I turn from this male to
female and that is amazing for me
[Music]
my name is Cassandra luxottica
I am a professional wrestler I've been
wrestling for 28 years I'm an exotic
Oulu teller which is a flamboyant
wrestler with glamour and style
[Music]
[Applause]
I always knew I was different I remember
when I was in second grade I think I was
like 7 or 8 years old and I already knew
I was I was gay I was taught that I
couldn't be gay I couldn't act this way
I couldn't dress this way I couldn't
talk this way because I was gonna burn
in hell when I was first called to be an
exotic car I was like wow freedom this
weight that I've been carrying for years
was just like melted down rhinestones
right in the dark I started using the
pantyhose the makeup the bathing suits
rhinestone feathers and boas and all
that because I wanted to be different
and that was the scariest moment but
when I saw the audience and the fans how
they took me in they were just like wow
look at him her.she I feel like a woman
inside
and then it's like this is me and that
transformation is beautiful something
happens when I get out of the dressing
room to the ring I'm still looking like
a woman I'm looking flamboyant and then
once I step in the ring my macho sigh
kicks in my mighty gotta be ready for
the fight all my title matches and
mostly all of my matches have been
against men
masked man like G stars over four pegs
and I've always been true to myself
it's Lucha Libre I'm not a beauty parlor
even though it looks like it sometimes
today I can tell you that being gay has
been a gift from God to me and I
understand that so that's why Lucha
Libre has always been one of my biggest
medications I I don't think I will ever
leave you cha libre this is what I've
done all my life
[Music]
[Music]
when I tell people that I'm a wrestler
they don't really believe me at first I
don't know what image they have in their
head of what a wrestler should look like
especially when I say I'm the super
heavyweight for women's wrestling and
they're like you wrestle like you're
you're kind of too pretty to wrestle and
so it's always interesting to me cuz I'm
like what did you expect my name is
adilyn gray I'm a three-time world
champion ranked number one in the world
been undefeated for two and a half years
and I'm gonna compete in the Rio Olympic
Games in August I never really
considered the Olympics as an option for
me when I was younger kid and it's
something that I don't think enough
girls have an opportunity to dream about
[Music]
I want to redefine feminine to some
extent and and to have people challenge
the way they look at the word strong and
not just see a boy that pops into your
head
I started wrestling boys I was six years
old and I wrestled boys all the way
through high school and I think I earned
a lot of respect from a lot of the the
teammates out there who did lose to me
or maybe beat me and I got to train with
the best guys in the world and they made
me tougher they made me work for every
single point I had to wrestle with and
and they made it so that I could be a
champion on the women's level now we
teach girls to be perfect and boys to
take risks I need to take risks that I
am a confident and strong female who
knows that I'm great at wrestling I'm
still struggling with that concept that
I'm worried about not being perfect when
I step on the mat
[Music]
I have to step on that mat and make sure
that I work every single moment to win
an Olympic gold medal I want young girls
to be able to look at thatmy situation
and be able to dream about it I'm
excited for that moment to have my five
risen and and be able to know that I'm
gonna hold a gold medal around my neck
[Music]